it is now two weeks since russia invaded
ukraine and to give his assessment of
the situation i'm joined by air marshal
edward stringer former director of
operations at the ministry of defense
now
ed that is not the map that president
putin would be hoping to look at two
weeks into the operation
no and as you can see the map really
doesn't appear to have changed that much
um uh in the last week
if we look into the south what we can
see here is that long-standing russian
ambition of a land bridge from crimea
which it grabbed in 2014 through the
donbass back into mother russia but also
what it's trying to do
is project forward further into the
black sea and to
and to seize
odessa
which is the uh is the the major port
um but what before i go further what i
do want to say is you don't win wars by
seizing all the territory you won't see
this whole map go red there won't be one
soldier in every square yard you do it
by seizing that critical national
infrastructure vital ground and the
centers of national government so
you know if we look in the north what we
can see there is obviously the reveal
plan
is well or was a two to three day opera
operation a lightning operation
to seize the capital to put in a puppet
regime to turn ukraine into a client
state and hope that 44 million
ukrainians would just accept that a
heroic assumption well let's take a
closer look at what this is happening in
the north then first of all of course we
have got uh the the attempts to open up
those uh humanitarian corridors and they
did work in in sumi and in the towns to
the uh west of kiev they didn't work so
well elsewhere unfortunately in ukraine
but you want to talk a little bit more
about what's happening around the
capital here
yes one of the bits that has changed is
you know this thrust we see here
from east to west aimed at kiev which we
must assume is directly related to that
convoy that we've been talking about
over the last week the 40-mile convoy
that's come
north to south aimed at kiev but now
looks very much like a self-inflicted
wound that looks like a
uh
40-mile roadblock that the russians have
put in on that vital line of
communication so this now looks like the
line of communication they're opening up
on this thrust into kiev but it looks
about two or three times as long as that
one and it's yet another logistic
challenge uh for them to solve clearly
what they're looking to do here is put
pressure on that centre of government
that seat of government of ukraine in
kiev and position themselves to uh
seize
some form of ground to give them a
better bargaining position to try and
find a political solution
and we
if we take a closer look then at uh
what's happening in in the air
we know from uh what's happened
overnight with the with the americans
the the offer to uh to the the migs from
poland uh into nato and then to ukraine
the americans didn't want any part of
that but the uk defense secretary uh has
said that the uk will supply missiles so
it's a subtle difference perhaps
well if you look at what ben wallace
defense secretary said what did the
missiles he talked about both had an
ante in front of them anti-tank missiles
and anti-air missiles
those are not a problem to you unless
you are yourself offensive and you're
driving tanks towards the ukrainian
defenders or you're flying flying your
aircraft in so they're purely defensive
missiles if there was no attack uh
happening against ukrainian forces then
those defensive weapons have no
offensive purpose hey marshall edward
stringer thank you very much indeed it
is a significant difference for nato